changing the world isn't always a good
thing even if it's with a really catchy
song a new character holds surprising
depths in the new one-piece movie and
her first song makes her plans clearer
than you think warning spoilers ahead
for one Piece Film red one Piece Film
red is the 15th movie adapted from a 25
year old manga series but its success
shows this franchise is anything but
tired film red broke records in Japanese
Cinemas netting more than 15 billion yen
in just over its first month of
availability and becoming one of the
most profitable releases to ever run in
Japanese theaters uniquely for the
series film red is something of a
musical while its characters don't
express themselves in song In
traditional musical theater fashion the
movie revolves around a new character
named utta who performs songs that
underscore the events of the movie in
total film red features seven songs
available to fans on a soundtrack EP
that effectively doubles as an album by
Adam the real life singer who performs
uda's vocals while UDA initially appears
to be an altogether happy and optimistic
pop star some heartbreaking events in
film red eventually reveal her true goal
while her purpose may be hidden from
viewers at first looking back on the
lyrics to the first song Buddha performs
in the movie hints at uda's true nature
whether
early on in one Piece Film red viewers
learned that utta became a popular
singer after broadcasting recordings of
her music all over the world in an
attempt to ease the lives of those
negatively impacted by the new age of
piracy part way into the film however
viewers find out that uda's singing
traps its listeners into a dream world
over which she has full control
furthermore in a dark twist she Harbors
intentions to end her own life taking
everyone trapped in her dream world
along with her her widely broadcast
concert and massive popularity leads to
her having influence over a significant
portion of the world's population who
she wants to help permanently escape
from suffering under piracy their decent
intentions but it's not a good plan the
first song UDA performs in film red is
titled new genesis while the song At
first seems to be about creating a
better world some lyrics betray a darker
meaning like say goodbye to everyone who
stands against us no one has the power
to stop a change that comes through
music and say goodbye to everything
that's weighing you down transcend
Beyond reality to colorful worlds of
Music the lyrics may sound innocuous
enough on the first listen but with the
benefit of hindsight uda's real plan
starts to become perfectly clear of
course uda's motivations are also
entirely understandable she sees other
people suffering and intends to use her
power to stop it when she sings lyrics
like we can choose the way of our future
try a brand new path if I change the
world she's not necessarily masking some
sort of hidden evil but simply
indicating that she wants to change the
world albeit in a misguided manner at
the film's climax Luffy naturally stops
UDA and saves the people trapped in her
dream world which isn't surprising
throughout all of one piece Luffy also
wants to change the world for the better
but does so by confronting and defeating
evil head on
UDA then serves as Luffy's foil in film
red sharing an interest and positive
change but acting on the goal in a more
antagonistic fashion film red producer
Shinji Shimizu highlighted uda's
uniqueness in an interview with anime
News Network he's said in one piece
films of the past there's always very
strong bad dare I say stereotypical
types of enemy figures that Luffy and
his gang would beat up and fight but
with this movie that is different
considering uda's appearance as a pop
Idol as opposed to a fearsome Warrior
he's certainly right about that but
regardless of her looks Buddha's
intentions to change the world
regardless of consequences are clear and
if you pay attention to the lyrics it's
all right there from the start
thank you
[Music]